Herr röttkin gleich die Frage an Sie ähm
weil auch ähm äh wer war es dieser Tage
Marco Buschmann der Justizminister die
Frage beantworten musste haben sie schon
im Wartezimmer warten müssen weil
Asylbewerber vor ihnen die
Wurzelbehandlung bekommen haben nein ist
mir noch nicht passiert wie fanden sie
diese
Aussage also ich sag mal der Satz war
die Leute werden wahnsinnig wenn Sie
sehen dass 300.000 Asylbewerber
abgelehnt sind nicht ausreißen aber
trotzdem die vollen Leistungen kriegen
die volle Heilfürsorge die sitzen beim
Arzt und lassen sich die Zähne neu
machen und die deutschen Bürger neben an
kriegen keine Termine gut also wenn Sie
mich fragen hätten Sie das auch so
gesagt dann kann ich Ihnen sagen ich
habe es noch nicht so gesagt ich hätte
es nicht gesagt und ich werde es auch
nicht sagen was macht man dann ruft man
dann an und sagt Friedrich was soll das
nein habe ich nicht gemacht aber
vielleicht kann ich trotzdem in der
Sache etwas ja ich würde auch mit ihm
darüber sprechen äh und wir haben dann
auch jetzt nächste Woche wieder in
Sitzungswoche ich will vielleicht in der
Sache sagen was was ich für wichtig
halte das eine ist glaube ich dass wir
klar machen dass wir eine Kontrolle dass
wir eine Begrenzung und Steuerung
brauchen ja das ist ja was anderes das
ist was anderes genaus genauso ist es
geht mir um einen Unterschied so das ist
das eine und das andere was genauso klar
sein muss ist dass die Menschen die hier
herkommen die vielleicht zu einer
Überlastung führen muss dennoch klar
sein es sind Menschen und wir gehen mit
Menschen anständig um wir machen nie
Politik gegen Menschen wir sprechen wir
wir wenden auch keine Sprache an gegen
Menschen weil das ist das Zentrum
unserer Politik das sind Menschen mit
würde und es ist unsere Identität zu
dies der CDU meinen sie nein das ist die
Identität unseres Landes der erste wir
haben ja äh der erste Satz unseres
Grundgesetzes lautet die würde die Würde
des Menschen ist
unantastbar ein ein gigantischer Satz
unantastbar und darum ist das das
Selbstverständnis unseres Staates die
CDU heißt christlich demokratische Union
und das eigentlich wenn ich wenn ich
mein Engagement und mein
Werteverständnis zusammenfasse dann ist
es der einzelne Mensch jeder einzelne
Mensch nicht der deutsche der Mensch
auch nicht nur die heute leben sondern
auch die künftigen Generation der Mensch
ist das Subjekt von Politik mit Freiheit
und Würde und so müssen wir mit jedem
Menschen und daraus das daraus folgt
dass jeder Mensch Respekt verdient und
auch wenn es große Probleme gibt müssen
wir zu diesem wollen wir zu diesem
wertverständnis stehen das muss immer
klar sein war das also
respektlos ich hätte so darum nicht
formuliert genau Frager warum macht er
das ich glaube er greibt eben
tatsächlich auf dem am rechten Rand er
möchte diese Stimmen haben weil er denkt
dort gibt es was zu holen das ist
natürlich auch die größere
Unterscheidung zur Mitte das ist ganz
klar äh in
diesem Verbund mit den
Koalitionsparteien kann sich die CDU
nicht so stark profilieren weil sie im
Grunde genommen in dieser Frage
eigentlich nicht wesentlich andere
Haltung hat
warum macht er das man könnte es auch
ein bisschen polemischer sagen weil er
nichts anzubieten hat zur Problemlösung
er hat ja nicht einen einzigen Vorschlag
bis zu diesem Satz gemacht wie man
tatsächlich mit der skrise umgehen kann
sondern er hat dazu verleitet und leider
sind ja dieser politische Betrieb ist so
wie er ist alle nur noch auf diesen Satz
se Tagen und Wochen sprechen wir nur
über diesen Satz wir reden nicht über
Lösungsansätze jedenfalls nicht in
dieser Klarheit nicht alles arbeitet
sich an ihm ab und berechtigterweise
wird die Frage gestellt kann so jemand
Kanzler und das das ist eine Frage die
werden wir sicherlich in ein paar
Monaten noch mal aufgreifen müssen und
wir werden
uns und auch heute aufgreifen und wir
werden uns auf jeden Fall immer an
diesem an diesen Satz erinnern er wird
damit nach Hause gehen er wird seine
Kanzlerkandidatur damit beerdigen können
das ist jetzt eine eine künenose das ist
eine kühne Prognose ich weiß aber da
müsste wirklich unglaublich viel kommen
dass er dieses Ruder noch mal rum
rumgerissenkriegt schau gerade zu Robert
Deininger Roman Deininger Entschuldigung
kann es sein Herr Deininger dass es in
München jemanden gibt in der
Staatskanzlei der sagt ganz gut wenn
solche Unfälle passieren passt schon pas
schon also weil es fällt ja auf also
Söder redet anders im Sommer als sich
Friedrich märz und Hendrik wüst in die
Haare gekriegt haben über wüst
Gastbeitrag in der Frankfurter
Allgemeinen da hat man schon von einigen
CSU dann gehört dass in nur noch das
Popcorn fehlt zum großen Glück auf der
Couch ja also riesen Ärger in der Union
und wir die CSU ist nicht mal Schuld so
hat man das gehört von denen ich glaube
aber dass das was jetzt passiert die
freuen sich wenn sich die die CDU
zerlegt ja also ich glaube jetzt freut
sich Markus Söder nicht über das was
gerade in der CDU und mit Friedrich März
passiert weil das negativ auf seinen
Wahlkampf abstahlt Markus Söder hat sich
ja 2018 massiv die Finger verbrannt am
Thema Migration er hat daraus gelernt
erst unter größten Druck aber immerhin
und er hat das Thema diesmal lange
weiträumig umfahren jetzt ist aber der
Problem behandlungsdruck so groß dass es
sich dem stellen muss er macht es aber
mit einer besseren Balance in der
Sprache zur Wahrheit gehört natürlich
das so Vorschlag wie die
integrations Grenze
nur politische Lyrik ist besonders
kreative natürlich mehr parole als
Programm
trotzdem ist momentan Friedrich merärz
der Problem Bär
das war Söder 2018 war öder hat sich
2018 im Ton vergriffen asyltourismus
jetzt hat man Herr märz mit seinen
zahnmedizinischen Einlassungen also mein
Gefühl ist man muss die Probleme bei der
Migration benennen und man muss es
stärker tun als es gerade SPD und Grüne
in der Bundesregierung tun und ich würde
man auch wünschen dass der Spielraum
gerade für die Union größer wäre also
bevor man quasi niederkatet wird weil
ein Wort verrutscht aber das wenn ich
das noch sagen darf was Friedrich März
gemacht hat ist natürlich ein Ton eine
Sprache die Menschen verächtlich macht
die resontiments weckt und das ist
natürlich einem dem Vorsitzenden einer
Volkspartei die das C auch noch im Namen
trägt tatsächlich nicht würdig und das
ist ja nicht das erste Mal das ist das
dritte vierte Mal die Paschas die die äh
sozialtouristen aus der Ukraine jetzt
dieses es es wäre ja fast die bessere
Erklärung wenn Absicht dahinter steckt
weil das dann wäre es zumindest eine
Strategie eine schlechte Strategie aber
es wäre eine Strategie wenn sie ihm
einfach immer wieder nur passiert diese
Fehler dann würde das glaube ich die
Zweifel in der CDU dass man den Mann
einen Bundestagswahlkampf aussetzen kann
steigern das passiert
doch glauben Sie Herr rötgenin dass
jemand wie kann der Kanzlerkandidat sein
also ich ich beäußere mich zu jeder
Frage die sie stellen aber ich bitte an
der Stelle auch wir müssen ja bescheuert
sein also wirklich bescheuert sein wenn
wir jetzt als Union zi Jahre vor der
Bundestagswahl bei der Problemlage die
das Land hat anfangen
aber provoziert solche Fragen ne die
stehen dann plötzlich im Raum sie sind
sie sind provoziert worden zu dieser
Frage daren sie das ist das ist okay
trotzdem sozusagen muss ich jetzt nicht
auf die provozierte Frage antworten weil
es es wäre wirklich bes okay dann frage
ich anders warum ist er nicht der
Richtige
ja ungefähr die gleiche Frage noch mal
ich w wir wir wä ich wäre bescheuert wir
wären bescheuert wenn wir jetzt auch
noch sie können das jetzt mit abscheuer
und Empörung zurückweisen und sagen wie
kommen Sie darauf unverschät natürlich
ist er der richtige haben sie nicht nein
nein absolut nein ich führe also ich
beteilige mich nicht ich kenne auch
keinen anderen der sich daran beteiligt
in dieser Lage die wir
haben die ist die ist besonders das ist
wir haben viele Themen die Menschen
Angst
machen wir haben Sorge dass ihren Status
verlieren wir haben jetzt wieder das
Thema das weil wir uns weil es ist also
erstmal muss man sagen das Thema ist in
der Sache wahnsinnig schwer aus ganz
vielen rechtlichen und tatsächlichen
Gründen ist es sehr schwer aber man
hätte natürlich anfangen müssen ich
würde sagen das der der wichtigste
Bereich aus meiner Sicht wäre wenn wir
diese Region aus der jetzt die
Bootsflüchtlinge kommen 180.000 bis Ende
September 180.000
wenn wir Nordafrika die sahelregion zu
einem strategischen Gebiet unserer
Außenpolitik gemacht hätten dass wir
jetzt wenn ein Problem da ist zu
Staatschef
Tunesien gehen sag bitte nimm un unser
Problem ab und dann kriegst du auch noch
Geld dafür sozusagen das kann ja gar
nicht funktionieren so das hät hat nicht
trotzdem irgendwie eine eine Tragik also
zwei Sachen ich unterstelle zum ersten
irgendwie ich erlebe ihn ja auch ab und
zu mal hier Friedrich märz ist kein
Rechtsaußen nein das ist kein
rechtsradikaler das ist ein ein Mann der
einen sehr klaren Kompass hat und von
dem man sagen würde klar der passt
perfekt in die CDU das ist ein
lupenreiner Demokrat klar ja so ganz
klar und dann hast du ein
Anliegen und dann hast du sie sagen wir
müssen die die die Kontrolle gewinnen
aber sie haben ein vorsitzend der hat
die Kontrolle über seine Zunge nicht
sondern der sagt Dinge über die dann
sich das ganze Land oder das halbeand
chaufiert die einen sagen endlich sagt's
mal einer und die anderen sagen wie kann
er nur bei den Paschas fand hier in der
Sendung statt war das gleiche ist immer
wieder das gleiche Muster es geht dann
immer am Ende das hat er zurückgenommen
hat sich entschuldigt das muss man jetzt
dann auch dazu sagen hat er aber das das
das Tragische ist wir reden dann immer
nur noch über Semantik wir reden nur
noch über die Frage darf man diese
Sprache so wählen statt über das
eigentliche Problem dahinter zu sprechen
und ich ich ich ich würde jemanden wie
fredich merzer gerne ernst nehmen ich
möchte doch gerne jemanden haben der
sagt pass auf es gibt da in Schulen ein
Problem wir haben da Jungs die haben ein
problematisches Frauenbild warum kann
man das nicht so formulieren dann würden
wir darüber diskutieren wie wir das
vielleicht in den Griff kriegen hier das
gleiche wir haben eine über lastung des
Gesundheitssystems an vielen Stellen das
Sagen Ärzte auch aber wenn du es dann so
machst dann ist es einfach nur noch
polemisch und zugespitzt das ist
doppelttragisch ja ich kann ich kann ja
nur immer für mich formulieren also und
ich habe gesagt wo die Unterscheidung zu
machen ist in der Kontrolle und die
Schwierigkeiten sie zu gewinnen das ist
leichter gesagt
aber ich glaube dass das das eine
Politik in dieser Region entscheidend
ist und das andere ist der Umgang und
die Sprache im Land bei allen Problemen
und sich dort auch klar abzugrenzen das
ist so sollten wir vorgehen und so würde
ich mich versucheners tragisch sie haben
ja fünf Punkte vorgestellt wie man das
Thema Migration wie das in Griff kriegen
K wir haben ein genau kein Mensch redet
mehr be diese fünf Punkte Antrag
eingebracht genau weil weil er dieses
zahnmedizinische Thema plötzlich
aufmacht also genau also aber wir machen
heute wir machen heute wir machen heute
aber wir müssen auch ein bisschen
darüber reden warum wir überhaupt und
dass wir wieder in dieser Lage sind es
ist ja nicht Friedrich März auch das ist
richtig das ist nicht Friedrich März
sondern wir haben überhaupt wieder die
Lage weil wir eine Regierung haben und
ich würde es wirklich also ich glaub ich
hoffe dass sie mir das glauben ich ich
würde wirklich gerne es nicht
kritisieren müssen aber wenn uns beiden
das im Ende Februar klar war was kommt
wir sind ja keine Experten wir sind noch
hab keine Ministerien die das alles
recherchieren also wenn wir es wissen
dann glaube ich hätte es die
Bundesregierung auch wissen können und
sie wusste es auch und die
bundesinnenministerin auch und alle
anderen in der Regierung richtig was was
passiert da eigentlich Herr R was
passiert da eigentlich ist ist warum
geht's da geht's da um Ideologie oder
warum also sousagen wollen wir Dinge aus
ideologischen Gründen schlicht
undgreifend nicht sehen die offenkundig
sind die Thematik ist ja derart virulent
wir hatten hier grüne Landräte sitzen ja
die sozusagen politisch sehr klar zu
verordnen sind die sagten Freunde so
geht's nicht weiter und es ist auch
völlig egal ob ich grün oder schwarz
oder was auch immer bin aber das kriegen
wir kriegen es nicht mehr in Griff also
wir haben das ja schon öfter mal hier
diskutiert und ich glaube es ist auch
ich halte das für das
entscheidende demokratieproblem das
haben wir inzwischen soweit geführt dass
wir in einer Krise der Demokratie sind
nicht als System sondern eine Krise des
Vertrauens in die Akteure
Kontrollverlust ja und das ist ein Teil
Kontroll genau und auch Kompetenzverlust
Kontrollverlust so und jetzt ist das in
so einem evidenten Fall schon wieder
passiert das ist ein kleineres Problem
sind die Grünen die da glaube ich sehr
ideologisch an dieser Stelle waren aber
das ist nicht entscheidend gewesen für
das nichtthandeln der Regierung wir
haben wir haben ein Muster wie in
Deutschland seit Jahren Politik gemacht
wird und auch da habe ich immer gesagt
das hat auch jetzt nicht erst mit dieser
Regierung
ler ist diese böse Regierung sind immer
die anderen und die een nie sondern das
haben wir seit Jahren ist das das Muster
ist dass wir nie vorausschauend handeln
gehandelt haben sie können eigentlich
nehmen was sie wollen obwohl das was
passiert voraussehbar oder mindestens
nicht auszuschließen war und
gleichzeitig findet nicht stad an Aktion
an Prävention um ein Thema und ein
Problem unter Kontrolle zu zu bringen
das ist hier jetzt wieder passiert wir
werden vielleicht gleich über die
Ukraine reden wo wir jetzt alle wissen
wenn das so weitergeht werden wir gar
keine industriekapazität mehr haben die
Ukraine militärisch zu unterstützen
unsere L sind alle leer weiß heute jeder
es geschieht nichts und sie könnten es
auf jedes auf auf ganz ganz viele Themen
so projuzieren es sind Regierungen die
sind in ihren Ämtern die sitzen da und
warten bis die Probleme kommen aber sie
haben keinen vorausschauende
Gestaltungsanspruch oder
Gestaltungsfähigkeit und das das das das
das zermürbt die Demokratie von innen
und das müssen Journalismus glaube ich
etwas schärfer mal
aufarbeiten ich würde gerne dieses
Stichwort Sahelzone
aufgreifen wir wissen seit
2013 dass die russische söltnertruppe
Wagner in Afrika ist wir wissen seit
2013 dass sie unter anderem nicht nur in
Syrien ist dass sie in der
Zentralafrikanischen Republik ist dass
sie in äh in Mali ist dass sie in
Burkina Faso ist und so weiter das sind
alles Länder die Kippen gerade sie
bringen sie haben einen riesiges
islamismusprblem das wird nur größer mit
Wagner das wird ja nicht geringer
sondern das wird größer dort wird
gezündet das sind 20 afrikanische Länder
in denen Russland drin ist und wir haben
spätestens doch an der Belarussisch
poolnischen bzw den baltischen Grenzen
gesehen dass Flüchtlinge als Waffe
eingesetzt werden sie mein wir werden
sozusagen wenn man diese Karte sieht von
beiden Seiten
quasi mit Hilfe
von in dem Fall Wagner
oder Interessen aus aus Moskau werden
wir in die Zange genommen das z.B
Afrikan weil es nichts gibt was uns so
sehr erschreckt afrianische Flüchtlinge
afghanische Flüchtlinge kommen aus
Zentralasien syrische ein bisschen
weiter südlich und aus aus Afrika aus
Nordafrika dann ein wirklich großer
großer Anteil von Leuten und wir wissen
seit 2015 dass wir dieses riesige
Problem haben wir haben es 2015 gerade
so geschafft wir schaffen das gerade so
geschafft 16 dann nach einem Jahr und
wir wussten dass wir etwas tun müssen
bei der
fluchtursachenbehebung dieses wunderbare
Wort haben wir alle mal ausstabieren
können und geschehen ist eigentlich kaum
etwas wir haben Russland in Afrika das
Feld überlassen und zwar komplett und
das mit Ansage es war ja nicht so dass
man das nicht wissen konnte das habe ich
das habe ich so noch gar nicht gesehen
dass das am Ende alles auch also
russische Geostrategie ist die da
stattfindet es es geht immer darum sich
natürlich auf der einen Seite Einfluss
zu verschaffen den Westen rauszudräen
also die ehemaligen kolonial Mächte aus
Afrika rauszudrengen sich dort neue
Stützpunkte Militärstützpunkte zu
erobern tatsächlich also die Welt global
sich neu einzuteilen und dann dieses
wichtigste für Europa wichtigste Problem
zu beforer nämlich Flüchtlinge zu
produzieren und das gelingt ih den
Westen zu also Geld zu machen auch
nebenbei noch und den Westen zu
destabilisieren an seiner
empfindlichsten Stelle
Stelle weil wir weil wir natürlich nicht
wie diktatorische Regime einfach die
Grenzen dicht machen und sagen genau
genau weil wir haben her wird
anschließen an Herrn win Begriff von der
Demokratie in der Krise weil ich nämlich
den Eindruck habe dass unser föderales
System gerade ins echtsen kommt weil
sich so viele Kommunen eben
alleingelassen fühlen mit diesen
Problemen
von der Landesebene vielleicht nur
einigermaßen verstanden von der
Bundesebene nicht mehr das war bei der
merkelreierung schon ein Problem bei der
Ampel habe ich das Gefühl dass die
Empathie für die kommunalarbeiter vor
Ort komplett fehlt und
wenn quasi innerhalb des dies dieses
Systems mal das Misstrauen sich
verbreitet dann ist es fatal auch für
das Vertrauen der Leute in diese
Demokratie K Mittel genau in Ihre
Problemlösungsfähigkeit Bund kürzt die
Mittel wofür ja für die unter für die
Versorgung der
Flüchtlinge an die Länder für die
Kommunen genau übgens wichtig
kurzag enormen Dimension wichtig zu
sagen dass dass die Probleme in den
Kommunen z.B von den Medien sehr
plastisch beschrieben werden weil sie
unsere Rolle angeschrieben haben also
wir weisen da schon drauf hin
sie müssen sie müssen sich engagieren
auch also das die Journalisten verhalten
sich ja ein bisschen ähnlich weil sie
sagen ein Problem das noch nicht da ist
das ist vielleicht nicht interessant es
gibt keine Klicks gibt keine Auflage
sondern die es gibt eine mediale Neigung
sich mit den Problemen dann zu
beschäftigen wenn sie da sind so wie die
Politik und sie fallen in dieser würde
ich mal so jetzt bisschen vielleicht ein
bisschen pauschal aber in der Rolle zu
sagen hier als als warenfunktion was sie
gerade bes rieben haben über Afrika das
hätte man schon das in der Rolle glaube
ich müssen auch die Medien eine Aufgabe
wahrnehmen der Politik nämlich Druck zu
machen Politik reagiert auf Druck wenn
die Medien als Quelle von Druck auf
Politik ausfallen dann über über
mangelen Druck hat sich noch kein
Politiker bei mir beschwert ich gerade
getan und dieselle sind der erste da
kann Herr deinger helfen
Herr müssen einfach mehr Gastbeiträge
absetzen das wä wahrscheinlich die
Lösung ist das andere Thema nur ganz gut
der Gedanke und vielleicht greifen sie
ih direkt auf Frau
Adler sie sagen da braucht's mehr Druck
von den Medien die Rolle der Medien
können wir gleich noch mal sprechen aber
ist nicht eines der Wurzel eines
sousagen die die Wurzel eines des Übels
das Politik nach Umfragen regiert dass
man immer
schaut tagesumfragen wie ist gerade die
Großwetterlage das können wir politisch
verkaufen das können wir nicht soll ich
mal ganz ehrlich sagen was meine Analyse
dazu ist natürlich gucken also erstmal
wollen Politiker wiedergewählt werden
Zeitungen wollen auch gut erfolgreich
sein sie wollen das ist ja alles
natürlich der Punkt ist
vielleicht kann ich das sogar Henry
Kissinger hat mir mal gesagt wie das mit
dem regieren ist er sagte seine
Erfahrung sei du kannst nur das Regieren
und machen was du im Kopf hast wenn du
in die Regierung kommst dann arbeitest
du deinen Kopf leer und in der Zeit kann
ja die Opposition ihren Kopf
vollarbeiten dann hat die wieder ihr
Programm im Kopf und so ist der
dem auch vielleicht schon mal tut mir
leid wenn ich mich wiederhole
aber die Idee ich fü noch mal ganz kurz
aus weil ich fand das ein sehr
interessanten Gedanken damals die Idee
war sozusagen wenn du ins Amt kommst
musst du ein klaren Plan haben weil
danach hast du keine Zeit mehr
nachzudenken war da musst du liefern und
zwar 14 Stunden am Tag da bist du im
Hamsterrad und sie sagen die haben jetzt
keine Zeit mehr das ist auch jetzt
wieder nicht ich bin es ist so ernst
dass das ist wirklich es wäre es ist das
falsch sagen die anderen sind es wir
sind super die anderen sind doof so ist
es leider nicht sondern auch diese
Regierung ist ins Amt gekommen sie
zelebriert und inszeniert das dann drei
Tage lang ohne einen Plan wir sehen das
jetzt auf dramatischerweise in selbst in
der Klimapolitik die Grünen sind stark
gewesen in den Zielen was Sie wollen
haben sich das auch schön geredet das
ist alles inherent ein Wachstumsprogramm
löst sich von selber aber wir sehen
jetzt sie hatten keinen Plan das ist das
Problem und das gilt auch für die
Migrationsfrage und sie haben auch
zurecht gesagt wenn dann noch mal sowas
wie die der ukrainekrieg oben drauf komm
dann kommt noch alles oben drauf dann
bist Du sowieso nur im reaktiven Modus
und das führt dazu dass die 14 Stunden
am Tag einfach ausgebucht sind sie
müssen liefern sie müssen irgendwas
bringen und haben gar nicht mehr die
Kapazität weil sie sie vorher nicht
erzeugt haben um vorausschauend Politik
zu machen da fehlt einfach die Ressource
dann wenn du da im Hamsterrad sitzt und
Luft
ich glaube es ich würde noch ein
bisschen früher ansetzen dass das was in
in der Bundespolitik doch wirklich sehr
ins Auge gefallen ist war dass
Außenpolitik sie haben es ja nur
wirklich am eigenen Leib quasi gespürt
Außenpolitik war einfach nichts womit
man Wahlen gewinnt Außenpolitik war so
uninteressant das war nicht wichtig da
hat man gedacht das sind ja alles
Orchideenfächer was sollen wir in die
Ukraine gucken was sollen wir nach in
die Zentralafrikanische Republik gucken
wen interessiert das hier uns uns
interessiert dass wir haben die Probleme
jetzt hier auf dem Tisch wir hätten seit
nicht nur seit 2014 oderit 2013 sehen
können was in der Ukraine los war das
war mit Ansage dieser Truppenaufmarsch
an der ukrainisch-russischen Grenze das
hat sich angebahn das war die gesamte
Putin Rhetorik war auf Krieg ausgelegt
und das haben also es es gibt ja kein
erkenntnisdefizit nicht das Geringste
nur es umzusetzen und zu sagen da bah
sich etw was an und ich muss versuchen
dann tatsächlich auch schnell zu
reagieren und natürlich auch den Mut
haben Sachen die ein bisschen
schwieriger sind trotzdem auch komplex
sind rterzubrechen dass man sie versteht
dafür werden Leute gewählt und noch mal
zum zum großen Thema Migration zu kommen
dieser Tag eine Zahl gelesen die fand
ich
atemberaubend wie oft ist gefeiert
worden dieses eutürkei Abkommen ja
stimmt es dass tatsächlich 4 oder 6000
Menschen überhaupt zurück ickt worden
sind jemals also wir haben 10 Milliarden
bezahlt und wir haben keine 10 000 Leute
zurückgeschickt aber sie sind nicht
gekommen das ist genau das ist war nicht
10 Milliarden würde ich sagen es waren
die Zahlungen sind auch dann nicht
erfolgt weil es das Abkommen auch nicht
also es war aber es waren Milliarden
aber ich glaube nicht zwei bin ziemlich
sicher nicht zweistellig sondern eher so
also einstelliger Zahl und
es der wesentliche Effekt war das soll
nicht kommen ja genau das das narrativ
so es lohnt sich nicht mehr aber es ist
im Wesentlichen nicht stark umgesetzt
worden das stimmt so und bei der
Rückführung waren wir schlecht das
konnte man wissen das konnte man sehen
dafür gibt Statistiken also das heißt an
dem Punkt ist doch auch schon ganz lange
klar da verrutscht uns etwas das
funktioniert ganz offenkundig nicht
jetzt ist die Frage was und wie und wie
brüchig das auch ist wir wussten auch
dass Erdogan jemand ist der dieses
diesen Tier eingegangen ist mit großen
Forderungen die wurden erfüllt und bei
dem kleinsten macht möglichen
Machtverlust auf seiner Seite hat er die
Flüchtlinge genauso eingesetzt er hat
allerdings auch die meisten er hat
auch aber es ist brüchig also mit
Diktatoren das ist natürlich wirklich
eine heikle Geschichte und dann
vergleicht natürlich auch ein
tunesischer Präsident was hat denn der
türkische Präsident gekriegt und ich
werde jetzt hier mit Almosen abgespeist
und guck noch mal in Richtung
Saudi-Arabien Krieg von dort das Geld
also nehme ich doch da und ja oder ma
diese Probleme gar nicht erst zu
eigen